what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and and guys if
you want to move the Overton window if
you want women to approach you left and
right you're thinking how do I get a
woman to approach me instead of
approaching them get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today I know what
you're thinking you're like
I really love pissed off women in the
comments section they're so funny
they're mad you know on Tick Tock
they're hilarious to watch well why not
get some in person get you a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today the link is
in the description okay
so um we have a couple stories we're
gonna go over today
um the first is a story that I saw
on Twitter as you guys know guys every
night I just go on Twitter and I tweet I
tweet tweet tweet I have all these
thoughts occasionally I even do a
Twitter space to just you know
spread these thoughts so
um I saw a video from Dom lucrae uh
talking about Western culture has
destroyed men and given women the
mindset of wanting more but providing
less and I've always I've talked about
this many many times how basically women
in the west we think were more important
than we are and we constantly have the
right in the left telling us we're so
special and the men must qualify to us
when really the natural order of society
is women qualifying to the men so the
Tweet was this is chilling cultures
destroyed man and given women the
mindset of wanting more while providing
less I pray for the mental health of men
and what this video does is give you an
insight into the average marriage today
now before you guys get triggered yes
there are exceptions but exceptions are
not the rule and unfortunately we live
in a society that does not acknowledge
female nature what is female nature it's
never being happy it's over exaggerating
things it's
um it's always trying to impose our will
on the men you know there's positives of
female nature can't think of any right
now but there are right
um but the problem is we can't
acknowledge the negatives without the
right and the left saying hey but not
all women are like that oh but hey
um you're going too far you're starting
a gender War
even though what we are talking about is
just facts men today are not happily
married wives do not have a good
reputation and you can see this where in
the mainstream media we have things like
happy wife happy life think about what
that implies her happiness which we know
women are never happy
dictates the success of the marriage
it's cheaper to keep her
um that indicates that many men want to
get rid of their wives but they don't
want to lose all of their then we
have man cave
basically implying that she gets the
whole house he is stuck in the basement
trying to get away from everyone because
his wife won't leave him alone uh but
let's see the video let's pull up the
video
oh
[Music]
foreign
Trope that we see in marriage this is
not just one instance this is really
common we saw it with Kanye before our
eyes where the woman lied to the
children about the father and there are
so many men that don't have access to
their children in this country there are
so many men where the woman was actually
the reason and the cause of the divorce
yet the kids think it was the father and
this is why I say time and time again I
I tell kids right or you know adult kids
now but ask your father for his side of
the story more often than not
it's not what the mom said we just have
this tendency to over exaggerate to blow
things out of proportion and
and children go through their life
hating their father even though their
dad really did everything right
and the sad part is a lot of men in this
process commit suicide you know and this
is why I
I just can't in good faith promote
marriage not the way it is today
um
I think families are good for society
but we really have to push for these
laws to be changed nothing we cannot
have a stable family unit without the
laws being changed it is not fair that
men have to gamble everything really for
women that
typically or over the age of 25
typically have some sort of past and
typically
um really don't add a lot of value to
that the average age of a wife in the UK
is 31. there's no Purity there's no
youth there and a lot of times they
bring in other men's kids
that and men go on the dating apps where
women have really high expectations we
only swipe right five percent of the
time and it's a vicious cycle where
Women's hypergamy has really gotten out
of control
and even more than that I think our
narcissism has gotten crazy out of
control because anytime anytime I bring
up a video like this right anytime I
point out these problems with marriage
one um the first thing that they bring
up is not all women are like that which
I I think that's like water is wet
and I also think it takes away from what
women's true nature every woman is
hypergament every woman has a nature to
impose her will on men now some women
are protected or they avoid it and they
don't end up going to that nature but
the point is women are a certain way and
the problem is we lie to men about the
way women are and act like we're these
sweet angels that can just do no wrong
when really
there aren't many wives nowadays that
submit and obey their husbands and this
is why I tell the guys
I honestly I would just throw out all
the chicks
pretty much over the age of like
24 even 23 these days and really just
get a younger chick
and mold her the older women
I mean maybe one or two can get through
that work really hard but and I say this
after interviewing hundreds and hundreds
of women and I just one day I asked
myself what percent of these women are
going to make really good wives
I don't know I thought maybe 10 out of
hundreds maybe 10.
um and that's really that's not a lot
and I I think it shows the state of
Western women today we've been lied to
about her nature and typically
um they've made institutions that really
protected women from ourselves you know
um they had our dad pick out her
husbands because clearly we make
horrible decisions
uh look look what's happened the last
hundred years when women have gotten
more and more Choice we've chosen poorly
right and we T we or the tendency for
women to go for men crazy out of our
league
um or for women to believe in like fairy
tales and delusion you know we used to
have the men protect us from this but
the problem is we've given men no power
and no Authority in this Society
and then wine when we're not protected
and the point is we're either equal or
we're not and if we're not equal then we
need to start giving up some of our
freedom to the men in order to have a
better society and that's where
I really get frustrated with um some of
the blue pill guys because they don't
understand that the root of all of these
issues is the policies that are passed
and we need to work to change the laws
in order to fix Society because women
we are just so easy to like propagate
like anything you put in into our ear we
just believe so it's like we have to use
that
and really use propaganda and media
techniques where the housewives are cool
again I know I know this sounds so silly
but guys cardi B is cool Kim Kardashian
is cool look at the role models women
have on TV
um men are not the same as women women
we want to be like the cool girl I don't
know what it is about us but like think
about this guys we are at home happily
with children and they convinced us just
with some propaganda so I say all right
this is my my theories all right I think
one the men have to marry virgins again
I think two they gotta propagate the
women right back I think we gotta put
some like women on TV that are just
really cool Housewives all right
um maybe ban us from social media I know
that's a little hypocritical
um
and and and change the divorce laws uh
women should know that if you leave this
marriage you are not getting your
children I think men should have
automatic custody
if men are paying child support I think
if you can't afford your kids give them
to the men that's my personal opinion on
it
why if I get a dog I have to afford it
like they check my finances I can't go
adopt a dog how crazy is it I can't go
adopt a dog
without them checking my finances to see
if I could afford it but these hoes can
have kids left and right and make the
men pay for it imagine now I'm gonna I
know kids aren't dogs okay I know I know
but imagine if I got a dog with a guy
and now I make the guy send me dog food
money every month that would be stupid
and I'd be like you can see the dog
three days a month you need to pay for
it we would all think that's silly
um and if she's a good mother the dad's
gonna want help anyway so he's gonna
give it's not men are men are a lot
Kinder than women
sorry ladies the last hundred years
when we have been given more freedom um
we really haven't been very nice with it
we haven't been very kind with it we've
taken rights away from men and really
treat men as a sub human class to be
honest with they don't have any rights
to their kids they have very few rights
in divorce court and this is what
happens when the politicians started
catering to what women wanted